how does a reishi mushroom like this
turn into something like this brick
researchers and companies are looking to
turn fungi into innovative materials for
buildings people live and work in
so what's propelling developers to swap
out conventional building materials for
fungi and how does these new building
materials compare to these more
traditional ones let's explore why
developers think that fungi are the
future
we're in a situation similar to what was
in the late 40s or early 50s when people
were just realizing what plastics would
do that's andreas merchant a researcher
at mit who's using fungi as the building
blocks of future houses so the mushrooms
predate insects and plants and
single-celled organisms they knew how to
survive on this planet before we did
before we arrived so they have a lot of
teachers i wanted to learn more about
the mushroom blocks so one of andres's
collaborators fungi architect chris mars
stopped by our office
so you sent me this brick
right here uh i was surprised at how
like woody it smelled uh what's what's
in it well it comes from wood actually
this this one is a sample of a material
that actually takes wood sawdust from
demolition uh construction and
demolition waste you can kind of hear
that it's it has the consistency of wood
it has about the weight of wood the
sawdust is held together by mycelium
which is the root-like system of
mushrooms in bricks like this the roots
act almost like a glue and they uh grow
in between the cells and actually hold
on to them bind them at a cellular level
the way that works is that the fungus is
actually digesting key plant proteins to
produce cayenne that's the main
component in the exoskeletons of insects
and crustaceans like beetles shrimp and
lobsters
and chitin is a pretty strong but
flexible material so you can think of
that as almost like a true plastic in a
sense when these chitin-containing
root-like systems grow in the wild they
are usually found underground when it
comes to harvesting mushrooms or making
blocks the process looks a little
different
those clear containers you see are
filled with mycelium and a substrate
which is made from woody waste material
a substrate is basically what an
organism like a fungus grows on the
project chris and andreas are working on
namibia to build houses uses oyster
mushrooms and mulch from an invasive
bush the type of mushroom and substrate
that are used can change the quality of
the end product you can get anything
from a very foamy material like a
insulation
or packaging styrofoam type
replacement or you can get something
very strong like this for bricks the
material needs to be compressed and then
baked to dehydrate it at the end of that
process chris says that you end up with
blocks that beat traditional building
materials on several key metrics among
the most important is strength we've
made materials that are up to 26
megapascals which is more than twice
what a concrete block is
and compression strength so the
compression strength means what exactly
compression strength is the ability to
take a downward pressure mushroom blocks
can also be more resistant than concrete
a withstanding impact like from this
sledgehammer
it's not the most scientific of tests
but it does give you an intuitive idea
of just how sturdy mushroom blocks are
plus it replaces it with something that
is insulative and can uh also resist
lateral loading things like earthquakes
without using steel that's an important
consideration as the world grapples with
climate change
concrete steel and aluminum account for
like 23 of the world's carbon emissions
plus he says they're biodegradable and
relatively lightweight
andreas told me that these blocks are
also fire [ __ ] which is a really
important quality in building materials
i decided to put that to the test
a little flame there we go
if i take it off it should go off
as expected
the official test will be much more
dramatic they'll have to set a scale
model of their fungi building on fire
chris says that another benefit is food
production so for every pound of that
waste bush we can actually grow a pound
of mushrooms the shrooms are growing in
namibia can also be harvested and sold
as food an important benefit given the
food and security there before habitable
mushroom buildings can come to fruition
the technology needs to be vetted
further that includes testing for
waterproofing bending strength
compression and fire safety the price of
production will also have to come down
right now they're way more expensive
than traditional bricks which can cost
less than a dollar
researchers and companies working to
make fungal materials mainstream are
confident that that will happen
regardless these new materials are a
good general reminder of just how
versatile mushrooms are thanks to
millions of years of evolution
[Music]
you